let me start off by telling you a story
six years ago a san francisco-based
startup had raised 120 million dollars
in venture capital
the product was a wi-fi enabled voice
controlled
sleek sexy looking product
but four years later it failed
that product that company was called
juicero
they had built a wi-fi enabled voice
controlled sleek
sexy looking polished turd
sorry but for seven hundred dollars the
machine
helps you squeeze juice packets
and not just any juice packets juicero
juice packets
you can use any other ones and each of
those cost an additional
five to seven dollars just to squeeze
a few more bucks out of you no pun
intended
but wait there's more you have to be
connected to wi-fi
for it to work so if you can't connect
to wi-fi
you can squeeze your juice
it didn't take long for people to
realize that you could just squeeze
those packets by hand
no expensive juice machine needed indeed
why do i tell you the story of juicero
well
hey it's a sleek looking product it
looks pretty easy to use
they must have done a lot of tactical
testing and evaluation
to make it run super smoothly i mean
it's just one button
but that's just it doing research
to improve its ease of use is only one
part of the whole
as felix lee said this earlier
good ux or good usability does not
necessarily
translate to value
the team must have forgotten to ask
whether it's solving a real problem
i mean just imagine the user story the
product must have had
you don't have to imagine too hard
because i wrote one for you as an
example
as a juice drinker i want to
purchase a wi-fi voice activated juice
machine that can press juice packets
so that i don't have to press my own
juice packets
all right all right kevin stop hating on
juicier we get it
the lesson here is that you can do tons
and tons of tactical research on the
product make it as
easy to use as possible but completely
miss the mark and
you're gonna encounter a lot of blind
spots to your users
evolving needs and you end up with
a polished turd
this is google maps
i'm sure most of you have heard of this
app it's an app where you can enter a
destination and it'll show you how to
get there
and give you an estimate of how long it
will take you to get there
now if you look at this image old
estimates might give you a window
of accuracy you invest a little bit more
money into technology you do a little
bit more research
and you'll get some higher precision
now if the team kept asking
how can we make it more precise
they would end up with something like
this
you will arrive in 8 minutes 17 seconds
59 milliseconds
and if they kept asking the same
questions they would get to the
nanoseconds
but does that mean this extra invested
research
and time to get this level of
incremental gain
translates to value the answer is no
at least not for your average user you
might need this
pinpoint level of precision if you're
going to
uh measure your trajectory to mars but
for your average user
it's really not worth your time
and that's the point we need to know
when to ask the right questions and
when to move on so that we aren't hit by
blind spots
tactical research is like spear fishing
in a small pond you can capture
the big fish early or easily and if you
keep focusing on the small pond you
won't have much to fish later
you've forgotten that there's a whole
ocean of fish as well
so this all this time i've been talking
about something called tactical research
but what is it you know the two examples
i just showed
are a real example and a hypothetical
example of continuous
tactical research so i like to define
this term
but first i want to zoom out let's take
a step back at all the different types
of research
there are i'm sure you've maybe
encountered some of these terms
generative research foundational
tactical scientific values
i'm losing my breath um but these are
the ones that i've heard of
so far at least and it can be confusing
so i'll try to break it down and
simplify everything
for you i've bucketed
this type of research into two main
categories see some
card sorting activity here uh the first
is strategic research which is
uh similar to foundational genitive
exploratory discovery
very similar type of research and on the
other hand we have
tactical research uh
where it's the same similar to a
relative
which consists of formative and
summative evaluations
are you confused yet good
so strategic research looks at the big
picture
long-term explorative adaptive
goals and usually this type of research
includes
building an understanding of something
something you don't know like your user
behaviors their sentiment
market opportunities the known
unknowns and the unknown unknowns
so examples of this kind of research
could include
knowing who you're wanting to know who
your users are what they do
their motivations etc
and on the other hand tactical research
focuses on
the implementation of specific design
recommendations that all serve
to achieve the overall product
or business strategy and examples of
this type of research could include
usability tests a b
test designing prototypes and the whole
purpose is to improve the
processes or workflows
now i've defined tactile research
now why it will not spark innovation and
i've called this the research
death spiral
this is the product death cycle
coined by david bland the author of
testing business ideas a book i
highly recommend as well you start with
the product
and maybe no one uses it you start
asking
customers what is missing what do you
want
they tell you you build the missing
features inevitably they're not using it
and then you do the same thing over
again
uh and asking users asking people what
they want
that's not true user research
and that's the product desk cycle
but what goes into product is research
so i'd like to
coin this term the tactical research
death spiral it's a mouthful but
a lot of organizations focus solely on
evaluative testing
after building something so you might
have built something
you conduct usability tests or tactical
research you fix those issues
and then you continuously ask the same
question
you build more features with the
improved usability and then you do
the test again and teams might end up a
b testing their way to hell
because a b tests are easy to run
expensive sometimes but easy
however without a prior foundation to
inform
the a b test hypotheses we would be on
running those a b tests blindly
the research teams are then tasks to do
tactical research
to fix something you know fix this fix
that after it's been built and by that
time
it's kind of too late
we can improve the product but this
won't lead to innovation
we test what we know
and we can make incremental improvements
to usability can you fix this
fix that it means it's a means of
putting a band-aid on problems and it
doesn't spark innovation
it it's making sure our design works
well we get
wireframes more usable designs
we need to do this type of research
don't get me wrong
but if you're polishing a turd it's
still a turd
and everything is based on decisions we
had already made
based on maybe assumptions
it's kind of like playing a video game
character and you decide to level up
only one skill
you get so ingrained in that one skill
you forget about everything else
the entire user experience
remember tactical research can only
answer
whether something is usable it doesn't
answer whether the
product is valuable you ignore the
context
the motivations the why
now you can get the why behind why
people aren't able to use something
but that's not the right question
why people want it to use in the first
place why
you know when do they want to use it who
are these people who want to use it
how these are the questions
so the opposite of reactive research is
proactive
so we need to be more proactive and do
more strategic
research or definitions time again
generative foundational research to help
us inform those early decisions
doing so not only saves us time from
building the wrong things and having to
fix them later
but we're able to explore what could be
rather than just having people tell us
what they think should be
so proactive research anticipates
decisions we need to make
and what does proactive research look
like
let me give you an example one of my
favorite stories
um is from the book creative confidence
by
tom and david kelly this is the mri
machine
at the university university of
pittsburgh
medical center the room itself would
be very dark with those flickering
fluorescent lights like an
out straight out of a horror movie and
for children it was a scary experience
they would cry they would get anxiety
about not wanting to go in
and even when they got in they were they
wouldn't be calm enough to
have good readings so it was a scary
experience and
a doc this would lead doctors to having
to repeat the scans over and over again
so this took up a lot of time and money
for the hospital
and it was a bad experience for kids now
if the staff
only gave band-aid solutions they might
have said you know here
have some candy or oh i promise it
doesn't hurt okay
yeah okay well look at that thing it's
gonna eat me uh
scary so what the researcher did
was go to a design thinking workshop at
stanford university
he learned to build empathy with the
patients and the parents
he observed them in the waiting room he
observed their behaviors he talked to
them
and he identified those anxieties and
fears
associated with this machine and then he
prototyped something called
the adventure series so what used to
look like this
now looked like the
this it wasn't a fancy tech solution it
didn't cost
hundreds of millions of dollars it was
simply
art but art that solved the problem
removing fears in children it helped the
hospital save a lot of time and money
by not having to do those repeat scans
they didn't have to use anesthetics
anymore
and it was so good that kids wanted to
go back
so the researcher had done some genital
research he explored the problem
at the core and that's what proactive
research
might look like
however the problem we might face in our
teams is ux researchers might not be
given a time
to do this type of research why is that
well the most common reasons would be ba
it takes research takes too long it's a
blocker it's a bottleneck
we have deadlines every two weeks
there's no there's no way we can do
research we don't have the time and we
can't make the time
so who's to blame
no nobody that's the nature of business
sometimes and
the great thing is the fact that teams
are asking for any kind of research
that's great that's progress
but i think the research death spiral is
also a
symptom of just not
knowing what value ux research can
really provide or not knowing when to
include ux research
in your process in fact
many times in non-ux mature teams or
companies
people have likely never seen the
benefit of any design
until they can see something tangible
something they can see feel and
measure and tactical research gives that
it gives
us the numbers like you can measure it
directly
it's easy to say we want to improve x
metric by
x percent next quarter it's easy to say
this
and then we do everything in our power
to squeeze out that incremental one
percent
and let's be honest sometimes we end up
thinking about
how do we get our users to do what we
want to get that one percent
rather than helping users
do what they need to do and want to do
okay so what
all right now we understand what
reactionary research is we understand
that death spiral and the symptoms of it
and how only doing tactical research
might only give you incremental ux
gains it's needed but it doesn't lead to
innovation
and innovation is one of the sticky
words in this talk title
so i like to break that down too we're
just doing definitions today
okay let's go the theme
this is some guy uh you might recognize
him he's elon musk
many people mistake him for an inventor
but he's really not he's not he didn't
invent
uh rockets or cars or solar panels
he's really a brilliant engineer and an
innovator
so innovation is not the same as
invention and innovation happens when an
idea
is improved upon combined with or used
in a creative way
that adds value and if you look at this
image
you wouldn't usually think to flip an
umbrella upside down
you break out of that functional
fixedness
it's something we like we call in
psychology terms you get so fixed on
how it's supposed to be used you forget
that you could probably use it in
creative ways
so innovation it it must solve
some user need people want it
it's desirable it must be
feasible you actually have to be able to
have the capacity or ability to build it
so you're using you operational
capabilities
and also must be good for business
that's
viability we have when you have all
these three
aspects then you could
innovate as uxers
everyone here today we have to balance
the users needs and business needs
and sometimes it's hard sometimes it's
hard to
only focus on the users only focus on
the business
what i like to remind people is that
without customers
you won't have a business so you should
you better be focusing on your customers
let me walk through a couple of examples
of innovative companies
and the difference between invention and
innovation
uber it's a rideshare app
they didn't invent rideshare though they
didn't invent taxis or gps
spacex another one of mr muss's
companies
they didn't invent rockets or propulsion
systems
and turbo tax is a us-based tax
filing app and what you can do with it
is take photos of your receipts and
finances and
it'll automatically help you with your
taxes
and it uses cameras but they didn't
invent the camera
or recognition software
what they did do was innovate they
leveraged the technologies for a working
business model
spacex uh looked at the main problem was
stage one two three of the rockets that
burned out the fuels
it's just space debris it just lands on
the ocean and becomes
garbage that's millions of dollars
so what they did was innovate on how do
we
get it back to earth so that we can
reuse it and save money
so innovated on reusable rockets
and turbo tax well they kind of
took all this existing information
technologies and
creatively put it together into a unique
way to do your taxes
all innovative companies
i want to show you a hyper simplified
user journey map
the one in the line the jig jag the
zigzag line in the red
is your current user's experience
uh and you might do strategic generative
research to understand
uh your user experience this way
the line up here in the curvy yellow one
that's where you want to be that's the
aspirational
user experience that's where you would
want your users to
to experience your product innovation
happens between that gap
when you bring your user your current
user experience up
to the aspirational the one that users
actually need
to perform efficiently that's where
innovation happens
to understand that gap you do strategic
research
use methods like diary studies to
understand how people behave over time
going out and observing people in their
context
how they do things why they do things
and you're going to learn things you
didn't expect to learn
now we have understood
all the definitions so if you only ever
do tactical research you'll only ever
play
ketchup so i'll give you some
i'll leave you with five ways to escape
this
tactical research death spiral when you
get stuck doing
tactical research only and be more
proactive in our research
i like to start off with the story when
i first joined google as a junior
researcher i was
tasked to do usability testing
i would plan a research meet the
participant
and focus on usability testing the
product
and what i did in the sessions in the
beginning for the first couple minutes
was
ask a few warm-up questions
have you ever heard of this product
would you ever consider
purchasing it why why not not the best
questions but they're just meant to warm
up people
i had no intention of using these
questions no intention of using this
data but i began to see patterns
patterns where i saw people didn't
really care for the product
so i i started thinking why are we
fixing
[Music]
these issues these usability issues if
no one
really cares for the product they didn't
see the value at all
remember good usability does not equate
to value so i went back to the team and
i suggested
we need to do some more strategic
research generative research
and this simple act of asking
adjacent questions and recognizing
that there is a problem outside of our
immediate scope
is what inspired a new innovative design
that sought to provide more value to
users
which brings me to that first tip inject
generative questions into your tactical
research
and a great place to do that is when
you're starting
your session with your participants the
introduction pre-study part
is a great place to warm up your
participants it's also a great time to
ask these questions
this helps us identify problems that
might not be top of mind for
stakeholders
second not we can save a bit of time by
conducting heuristic evaluations before
testing
we can find those blatant ux issues
first
then we don't need to spend as much time
doing full on testing of course it's not
a replacement
for actual usability testing which is
still tests with
real users to find unexpected problems
because after all we're not the users
this can help save us some time
and why do we want to save this time
to carve out you know time to do
generative research
the third another way you can employ
more proactive research is establish
programs to streamline those tactical
requests
if we know that some research
from stakeholders are coming in if we
know ahead of time
that stakeholders want this usability
test done this av test done
we can create a cadence for evaluative
research
to anticipate upcoming needs
so at my previous companies we had
something called rolling studies
where we would establish every two or
three weeks there's going to be some
time to do
tactical research and the whole team
would know about it
so they know that their first is a
cadence they know when research is
happening and they know what it's for
that let us
do carve out time although outside of
these
programs to do generative research as
well
another one was uh google likes doing
trusted testers
you have a base of trusted
participants and customers you can tap
into
all the time and then another one is
called around the world
speed dating okay this how this works is
you have a room full of participants at
each different tables
of course during covid you might have
different breakout rooms
uh where each participant sits and what
happens is
you have a team or stakeholder with
their particular
tactical research requests speak to each
participant in every room and
you might spend 15 minutes each and then
you rotate
rooms so that you can scale up the
research
instead of just trying to scale up the
researcher
okay this is a great way not only to
scale the research but also
involving your stakeholders in the
research with you
fourth
many times product road maps are planned
out based on guesses or
assumptions
question those assumptions
if you find that you don't have ample
evidence to start building anything
then you need to push for that
generative research and it doesn't have
to be
like oh we're going to completely flip
the table and do generative research
start with
10 of your time it doesn't have to be a
lot
then 15 then 20 maybe even 30
then 50. propose this generative
research
um that won't curtail the current
efforts
but get buy-in for trying and pitch it
as
getting ahead of the curve right future
proofing your product
your strategy by understanding trends
and being proactive rather than reactive
whereas much problem spotters
as we are problem solvers and the point
of all this is being able to explore
areas that we are we might be blind to
and finally we know this
involve your partners and involve them
early and get involved
ideally of course we'd be involved right
from the get-go
right from the very beginning of
projects so that we can help steer the
ship
how do you do this have constant
one-on-one meetings with
cross-functional partners
uh know what they're up to know what
kind of project initiatives they have
what kind of questions that they're
asking
and get alignment on existing emerging
project initiatives
another way you can do this is lead and
facilitate research
share outs presentations or sprints
so that research can be the foundation
for these
projects right for these solution-based
efforts
we want research at the foundation
and lastly get stakeholders in your
research sessions
just the other day uh there was a very
outspoken stakeholder
very solution focused and we had him
watch a video of a participant and it
completely changed the tone
so have them observe users show videos
and quotes
it's cliche we know this but it is
powerful
doing this amplifies your leadership
as a uxer an ability to influence
crucial parts
of your product strategy before you ever
need to react to surprises
surprises like the research death spiral
and that's it for me thank you uh you
can find me on these socials
um and a shameless plug actually
what you just heard is actually an
excerpt from
something that i've been working on i
created a ux research master class
which you can find at 02x.com
masterclass
so thank you